Aaron Kina is dead feylau has turned it
back on the division and gone Rogue
teaming up with Barton Schaefer and the
Black Tusk
following the events of Warlords of New
York we are introduced to a new content
format called seasons
in this video I'll be summarizing what
has played out across seasons one to
eleven
[Music]
what comes next
the volcano's death he had organized an
attack on Washington DC rogue agent
Jupiter was given the task of carrying
this out
Jupiter assembled her team of Rogue
agents and equipped them with the new
rogue Network smart watches that agent
Theo Parnell had developed alongside
Kina
while on Mission Jupiter would receive a
package keynote's enter a sample of his
new weaponized Eclipse virus
both Keenan now out of the picture she
had it disposed of
to her this operation was about getting
rid of the virus not spreading something
far more dangerous
Jupiter and the Rogues have teamed up
with the cleaners for this mission she
informs them of multiple reports of
experiments being carried out to
weaponize the virus in DC it makes it
very clear that the goal is to eradicate
the green poison and anyone who could be
spreading it
following the path of Destruction
division agents would eventually catch
up with Jupiter's Rogues and take them
out one by one
it was discovered that Jupiter was on
Roosevelt Island uncovering a newly
developed EMP technology from a cargo
plane that had crashed there some time
ago this Tech was capable of
neutralizing all non-rogue Network shd
Tech including the agent's armor
her plan was to recover all the tech and
dispatch it out to Rogue agents
Nationwide rendering the division
completely helpless
by the time division agents caught up
with the the cleaners had set up a solid
foothold on the island and were
preparing to use it as a staging point
for the emission of cleansing Washington
DC of the virus by burning it to the
ground
but the agents were too much for them
the cleaners were pushed back
even after Jupiter had them utilize the
new EMP gems against them they fought
through killing the cleaners the emps
and eventually Jupiter
rogue agent Hornet had history with Kina
they served together in the U.S army
long before they were recruited by the
division
Hornet saw them as brothers and would do
anything that was asked of them
during keena's attack on Lower Manhattan
he gave Hornet some of the eclipse virus
along with instructions of how to create
more
on top of this he tasked Hornet with
going to Washington DC along with four
other Rogue agents to recruit members to
his cause
the outcasts were the most likely
solution as they were currently without
a leader and in need of a purpose
but Hornet's Rogue agents weren't
exactly the most subtle in their
movements division agents had no problem
tracking them down and eliminating them
eventually exposing his location at
Tidal Basin
Hornet to the space to organize his new
Outcast recruits and get a supplies of
eclipse virus moved out of the city
but the agents were pushing through the
compound too quickly
Hornet attempted to slow them down by
releasing some of the virus around the
base however it was too late the agents
were able to clear the outcast forces
and then haunt it in a stockpile of
eclipse virus
Black Tusk specialist leader Barden
Schaefer his has been tasked with
working alongside the recently turned
Rogue they Lao
she has provided him with full Rogue
agents but he is having his doubts and
shares his concerns with Black Tusk
leader Natalia Sokolova
but Natalia shakes it off saying that
this is an opportunity for Fey and her
Rogues to prove their worth as well as
keeping a business partners happy she
orders Schaefer to handle the
responsibility as it was him who brought
Faye to the black task in the first
place
during the operation Jeffer continued to
receive unreasonable requests from these
Rogue agents until he eventually decided
it was time to contact feylau
they would end up organizing a meeting
on Coney Island to discuss the operation
and growing expenses
in the meantime chaffer's Rogues are
being hunted down by the division with
the assistance of someone or something
that refuses to stop and talk and
instead opts to disappear after each
encounter
from the outside the Schaefer and fame
meeting appeared as a setup to kill Faye
but regardless of what it was intended
to be used for the shd agents would soon
crash the party before anything was able
to go down they would invade Coney
Island rapidly working their way through
the Rikers stationed there and meet face
to face with the entity that was
responsible for helping with hunting
down the Rogue agents
this asset or operative would be taken
down by the agents but he seemed to be
known by Shafer in Natalia in fact he
seemed to be working with them
the agents would turn their attention to
Schaefer after engaging with some of the
most elite btsu in their ranks h were
able to catch up with them and after a
short firefight Schaefer would become
severely wounded
Elaine Kelso would send in a team to
retrieve an apprehendum
agents finally discover Intel on
feylau's whereabouts given her
prominence within the agency her actions
in turning her back on the division make
him more than just another rogue agent
Target
for the agents this is personal
after taking down a team of Rogues they
would find out that she is at Camp White
Oak with President Ellis
but by the time the agents get there
they has assassinated Ellis and is
attempting to escape the compound via
helicopter
blaming the division for Alice's death
she is surrounded by a large contingent
of black task forces
before she is able to leave the agents
catch up with a disable the transport
Bay is now forced to engage in a fight
against the agents she once worked so
closely with
they would eventually be killed by the
agents but after a death they would
discover that not everything was what it
seemed
audio logs left by Faye would explain
that everything she has been doing is
for the greater good of the division in
the country
her plan was to gain trust within the
Black Tusk and work her way up through
their ranks to put herself into a
position where she could take them apart
from the inside and her first Target was
President Ellis
she needed everything to look authentic
it needed to appear as if she was just
another agent defecting from the
division
so for this reason she couldn't let
anyone know what she was doing
on top of this she was working closely
with bud and Shafer who had lost faith
in the direction the Black Tusk was
headed
as Natalia's number one man in the btsu
he holds a large amount of intel on what
Natalya and her partners are planning
but for now he is still in a coma from
his engagement with the division at the
end of season three
seasons 5 6 7 and 8 are just repeats of
seasons one to four but not in the same
order which is a little bit weird the
only reason I'm including the section in
the video is to explain why the content
I'm about to run through jumps from
season 4 to season 9.
when the jtf was assembled in Washington
DC Captain Lewis would be placed under
the command of Colonel Antoine Ridgeway
when Ridgeway stopped taking orders from
above and started taking matters into
his own hands Lewis was one of the
soldiers who would stay loyal to his
cause rebranding themselves as the true
Sons
after ridgway's death at the hands of
the division General Anderson would take
the reins
Anderson would eventually have Lewis
carry out an operation in DC they were
hunting for something and have now found
it
Lewis and his men head to the Jefferson
Trade Center immediately and this is
where the division would catch up with
them
except he is all alone the last member
of his team
Lewis would explain that there is
something much louder at play here in
regardless of their differences they
should team up to bring it down
although they don't necessarily trust
him the agents agree
the division along with Lewis get to
work taking down the black task who have
taken hold of the site
while in there Lewis warns the agents
that the btsu are not the biggest threat
present on site there is something far
more dangerous something he calls the
recruiter
agents eventually take down the Black
Tusk forces
the recruiter having done nothing but
observe from a distance throughout the
fight would vanish shortly after
however to add to this confusion the
agents would also find out that the
Black Tusk soldier who is commanding
this operation had an agent watch on him
with Isaac detecting an agent status
the agents pushed Lewis for answers but
he would simply tell them to get in
contact with them when they had finally
caught up with what was happening around
them
this operation also reveals and confirms
the cooperation between Natalia Sokolova
and Kelvin McManus
McManus turns out to be the Secretary of
Homeland Security and that he is his own
personal unit of covert special
operatives known to us as the hunters
being Homeland Security McManus is not
only aware of the shd from its very
early days but is somewhat responsible
for them
General Anderson has come to the
realization that the true sons are no
match for the division or the Black Tusk
so as reached out to Natalia Sokolova in
an attempt to team up
Natalia sends out a team of Black Tusk
operatives to assess and work out the
viability of this potential new alliance
however in the background many in
Captain Lewis have been communicating
prior to more recent events Manny and
Lewis worked alongside each other in the
jtf all the way up until the day that
Colonel Antoine Ridgeway turned his back
on the government after losing faith in
their ability to do what was needed to
make it through the pandemic
the jtf round Bridgeway were faced with
a choice to fall back to other jtf units
or to join his new band calling
themselves the true sons in turn
becoming an enemy of the country
many fell back keeping to his oath while
Lewis sided with Ridgeway agreeing that
things needed to be done differently if
the country was going to survive
however now after ridgeway's death
although Lewis still feels that what he
did was justified under Anderson things
have now changed and he wants to help
put a stop to Anderson and Natalia's
plans
he's managed to find at least 100 True
Sons so far who are willing to follow
him and team up with the division to
take Anderson down
but unfortunately for him Anderson and
Natalia are onto him and have been
watching for a while
before he was able to move out Captain
Lewis and the majority of his true Sons
were rounded up and either locked away
or executed
after the division had finished dealing
with Natalia's black task operatives who
were sent in to assist the true Sons
agents would discover General Anderson's
location at the pink Co Fairview power
plant where he had a meeting planned
with Natalia Circle over
agents would make their way to the
reactor there Lewis have been locked
away in an office and the compound is on
fire
division agents were successful in
locating the valves and reactivating the
sprinklers rescuing Lewis in the process
but with little warning Lewis took off
in pursuit of Anderson
however Anderson had already made it to
the docks where Natalia had arrived with
a fleet of hovercrafts
the agents would meet up with Lewis in
the parking lot where a helicopter was
waiting to extract them
after the events at the pink Cove
Fairview power plant the Black Tusk and
true sons have successfully rebuilt
their Alliance and are now working
together to destroy the division once
and for all
stovepop and his team have been tasked
with Gathering Intel on the White House
would lead to them finding out that
Barton Shafer is still alive
on top of this Natalia Sokolova appears
to have her own plans in place that she
is keeping from her team
it has something to do with radiation
and dirty bombs while she is denying it
her intentions are clear
it would eventually be discovered that
stovepipe has been building a base with
more Thai launchers on Coney Island
agents realized this could be her plan
to launch a dirty bomb attack on New
York city so they quickly make their way
over there to put a stop to it
however when the agents arrived on the
island it was quiet
they would discover that stovepipe was
dead and that the whole operation was a
trap
from a nearby Black Tusk coppercraft a
swarm of drones quadcopters mini tanks
automated turrets and emps would be
launched towards the agent's location
fighting through and clearing the island
Torres was able to make it to their
location and extract them
however this is when the true depth of
the situation really came to light
it turns out that Natalya had figured
out that the division were listening
into their comms and decided to use this
to lure the agents away while she
organized an attack on the White House
so while the agents were distracted and
Away on Coney Island looking for
something that didn't exist the Black
Tusk rolled in their main target Barton
Shafer
the shd network has once again been
taken down but thanks to a mobile shd
server agents are still able to
communicate and use skills
fighting through the Black Tusk they
meet up with Kelso most of the attackers
have either left or been killed jtf
bodies line the floor and this includes
Captain Lewis who sacrificed himself so
that many and Schaefer could make it to
a Panic Room
they know that Schaefer was the Target
and while the black tasks were
unsuccessful in taking him they still
managed to take the perfusion bioreactor
and several key personnel
the next step is to get the White House
defenses back online
as long as they have the mobile shd
server while Limited in range their
skills and cons are working
but they also need to figure out whether
this shd network blackout is just local
or is in fact a global shutdown
like I said at the beginning of this
video the intention was to provide a
concise summary of The Story of All
Seasons up until now
with year 5 almost here I wanted a place
I could Point people towards if they
were wanting a quick recap
I'd actually hoped that I could make
this a little shorter but when
attempting to do so I felt as though too
much of the important information was
being lost
but hopefully this answers the question
of What story did I miss in the seasons
that I often see being asked the full
version of this video will be out in a
few days this one will be more for the
Die Hard fans as it will be an edited
compilation of all full-length videos
and will sit somewhere between four and
five hours long
anyway thank you very much for watching
and extremist malice extremely remedial
[Music]
[Applause]